Dear fellow scholars.
This is two minute papers with Dr. [inaudible] due to popular request.
Today,
we will talk about Neuralink Elon Musk's neural engineering company that he
created to develop brain machine interfaces.
And your first question likely is why talk about Neurolink now there was a
recent event and another one last year as well. Why did I not cover that?
Well,
the launch event from last year in these promised a great deal in this series,
we often look at research works that are just one year apart and Marvel at the
difference. Scientists have been able to make in that tiny, tiny timeframe.
So first let's talk about their paper from 2019, which will be incredible.
And then see how far they have come in a year,
which as you will see is even more incredible.
The promise is to be able to read and write information to,
and from the brain to accomplish this. As of 2019,
they used this robot to insert the electrodes into your brain tissue.
You can see the insertion process here from the closeup image.
You might think that this is a huge needle, but in fact,
this needle is extremely tiny. You can see a penny for scale here.
This is the story of how this rat got equipped with a USB port.
As this process is almost like inserting microphones into its brain.
Now we are able to read the neuro signals of this rat.
Normally these are analog signals,
which are red and digitized by neural links implant.
And now this brain data is represented as a digital signal. Well,
at first, this looks a bit like gibberish.
Do we really have to undergo a brain surgery to get a bunch of these quickly
curves? What do these really do for us? We can have the neural link chip,
analyze the signals and look for action potentials in them.
These are also referred to as spikes because of their shape.
That sounds a bit better, but still what does this do for us?
Let's see here, we have a person with a mouse in their hand.
This is an outward movement with the mouse and then reaching back simple
enough.
Now what you see here below is the activity of an example in neuron.
When nothing is happening, there is some firing, but not much activity.
And now look when reaching out this neuron fires a great deal.
And suddenly when reaching back again, nearly no activity.
And this means that this neuron is tuned for an outward motion.
And this other one is tuned for the returning motion and all this is now
information that we can read in real time. And the more neurons we can read,
the more complex motion we can read. Absolutely incredible.
However, this is still a little difficult to read.
So let's order them by what kind of motion makes them excited and dare
we go suddenly this is a much more organized way to present all this neuro
activity. And now we can detect what kind of motion the brain is thinking about.
This was the reading part, and that's just a start.
What is even cooler is that we can just invert this process,
read the spiking activity. And just by looking at these,
we can reconstruct the motion.
The human wishes to perform with this brain machine interfaces can be created
for people with all kinds of disabilities,
where the brain can still think about the movement,
but the connection to the rest of the body is severed. Now,
these people only have to think about moving and then,
then yearling device will read it and performed the cursor movement for them.
It really feels like we live in a science fiction world and all the signal
processing is now possible automatically. And in real time,
and all we need for this is this tiny,
tiny chip that takes just a few square millimeters. And don't forget,
that is just version one from 2019.
Now onwards to the 2020 event where it gets even better
than your rolling device has been placed into Gertrude, the pig's brain.
And here you'll see it in action. We see the rest of you here.
And luckily we already know what it means.
This lays bare the neuro action potentials before our eyes or in
afterwards, which neuron is spiking. And exactly when below with blue,
you see these activities summed up for our convenience and this way you will not
only see, but here too, as these neurons are tuned for snout boobs.
In other words, you will see and hear that the more does not is stimulated.
The more neural activity, it will show less listen,
And all this is possible today. And in real time,
that was one of the highlights of the 2020 progress update event.
But it went further much further. Look,
this is a pig on a treadmill, and here you'll see the rain signal readings.
This signal marked with a circle shows where a joint or limb is about to
move where the utter dimmer colored signal is.
The chips prediction as to what is about to happen.
It takes into consideration periodicity and predicts higher frequency movement.
Like the sharp turns really well.
The two are almost identical,
and that means exactly what you think it means today.
We can not only read and write,
but even predict what the pig's brain is about to do.
And that was the part where I fell off the chair.
When I watched this event live,
you can also see the real and predicted workspace positions for these body parts
as well. Very close. Now,
note that there's a vast body of research in brain machine interfaces.
And many of these were possible in lab conditions and neural links quest
here is to make them accessible for a wider audience within the next decade.
If this project further improves at this rate,
it could help many paralyzed people around the world live a longer and more
meaningful life.
And then your all enhancement aspect is also not out of question.
Just thinking about summoning.
Your Tesla might also summon it with sounds like science fiction.
And based on these results,
you see that it may even be one of the simplest tasks for a neural link chip in
the future. And who knows one day, maybe with this device,
these videos could be beat into your brain much quicker.
And this series would have to be renamed from two minute papers to two second
papers, or maybe even two microsecond papers.
They might actually fit into two minutes.
Like the title says now that would truly be a miracle. Huge,
thanks to scientists and neuro link for our discussions about the concepts
described in this video, and then ensuring that you get accurate information.
This is one of the reasons why our coverage of the 2020 event is way too late
compared to many mainstream media outlets, which leads to a great deal,
less views for us, but it doesn't matter. We are not maximizing views. Here.
We are maximizing learning note that they are also hiring.
If you wish to be a part of their vision and work with them,
make sure to apply the link is available in the video description.
This episode has been supported by weights and biases in this post.
They show you how to train and compare powerful modern language models,
such as bird and this tail bird from the hugging face,
library weights and biases provides tools to track your experiments in your deep
learning projects. Their system is designed to save you a ton of time and money,
and it is actively used in projects at prestigious labs,
such as open AI Toyota research GitHub and more.
And the best part is that if you have an open source academic or personal
project, you can use their tools for free. It really is as good as it gets.
Make sure to visit them through
wnb.com/papers or click the link in the video description to start tracking your
experiments in five minutes,
our thanks to weights and biases for their longstanding support and for helping
us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.